marta morales de 70 años ha recorrido
las cárceles durante días buscando a
tres de sus familiares que fueron
detenidos en medio del estado de
excepción declarado por el gobierno
salvadoreño a finales del mes de marzo
mire yo lo que más quisiera desde que
estas cosas llegarán a nuestro señor
presidente porque él ha ordenado que se
capturen a los delincuentes no las
personas civiles y yo siento que van
parejos o sea no entiendo por qué
capturan a las personas que no tienen
nada que ver con cosas delictivas
si bien el gobierno asegura que las
capturas son de integrantes de pandillas
organizaciones de derechos humanos
reportan centenares de arrestos
arbitrarios los familiares de los
detenidos confirman que los arrestos son
sin orden judicial y sin investigación
las autoridades de seguridad han
reconocido la muerte de 11 personas bajo
custodia penitenciaria entre ellos el de
william gallas
la última vez que lo vi fue ese día por
la mañana
y casi un mes después lo veo pero no en
las condiciones que yo quería no es
parte del alma toda la familia
del otro lado de la ciudad víctor su
liga no tiene tiempo para ir a preguntar
por su pareja arrestada a inicios de
mayo ya que tiene que trabajar y cuidar
a la hija de ambos de apenas nueve meses
porque la gente la escucha y oral
pero no lloro de dolor sino que de
angustia por el olor a madre por el
sentimiento de la madre
el temor de víctor es no volver a ver a
su compañera el de los defensores de
derechos humanos es que la
transgresiones se vuelva una situación
permanente mientras el gobierno celebra
la efectividad de las medidas especiales
que fueron extendidas por otros 30 días
cada vez son más las personas que
abarrotan las afueras de las cárceles en
búsqueda de sus familiares detenidos